I didn't get on a plane and fly other
than flying from Africa to the UK until
I was like 21 so we didn't do holidays
in our family the money wasn't there and
I remember getting on that plane when I
was 21 years old with my business part
at the time flying to Thailand and
economy and just being captivated by
this concept of being in this tin can
and we were going to attempt to fly to
Thailand and I'm looking at the like
safety manual I'm like it's amazing it's
so such an incredible experience I was
so happy on that flight fast forward
five fast forward 5 years I'm flying
5050 weeks a year in 2019 F flying
business in first class and all I'm
doing is rushing on the plane throwing
my bag up and pulling my laptop out as
fast as I can before it takes off so I
don't lose Wi-Fi and then that day I
encounter the lady next to me on the
plane he's probably on like a honeymoon
or
so she's like putting on the slippers
and she's going Dave Dave look at this
catalog and they give you champagne and
she's picking it up and she's sipping it
and she's old
me and she's experiencing the joy that I
used to experience when my expectations
were exceeded and nothing has changed in
my life other than my expectations have
increased yeah and with that out the
door has gone my joy so what I can do
now and what I do now is when I get on
the plane just before I step in I touch
the top of the plane and I take a moment
before I step on and just remind myself
of the absurdity that I I'm I'm getting
in this plane we're going to fly it
somewhere and I get to sit in this comfy
chair that reclines and when they bring
over the sh that's so incredible you can
influence your joy if you manage your
expectations hey friends thank you so
much for watching if you enjoyed this
clip then click here for the full
unedited episode and if you like that
then do please consider subscribing to
the channel it means a lot thank you so
much and have a great day bye-bye